bonsoir claude blanche maison mère s'il
est avec nous en direct alors que
peut-on retenir de cette rencontre entre
angela merkel emmanuel macron à ce que
des informations ont filtré chancelière
angela merkel et le président macron ont
en effet envisager la la manière de
coordonner les politiques allemandes et
françaises au cours des six prochains
mois puisque comme vous pouvez le lire
après demain commence la présidence
allemande du conseil de l'union
européenne
c'est une présidence qui tournent tous
les six mois et c'est très important
quand un pays fondateur de l'union
européenne comme l'allemagne exerce
cette présidence alors évidemment l'un
des points immédiat puisqu'il y aura un
conseil européen les 17 et 18 juillet
prochains
et avec le déplacement physique des
chefs d'état gouvernement comme
aujourd'hui il y avait un déplacement
physique de monsieur macron à mais ce
verbe on entre donc dans la presse
coronavirus eh bien on attend si
possible un accord sur la proposition
faite par la commission cette
proposition d'un emprunt de 750
milliards d'euros dont 500 seraient
consacrés à des subventions budgétaires
aux états qui ont subi les conséquences
les plus graves
banderas crise du coronavirus et 250 à
des prêts également pour les états qui
ont subi les conséquences les plus
sévères
pendant pendant la crise alors on sait
que ceux ci butent sur les réserves très
forte
l'opposition de quatre états qu'on a
appelée frugaux d'ailleurs je sais pas
très bien pourquoi un journaliste autre
jour les a appelés de radin c'est
peut-être plus justifiée puisque ce sont
quatre et à qui il aurait déjà bénéficié
d'une réduction dans leur contribution
au budget de l'union européenne
c'est un héritage de la réduction
britannique mais qui va cesser avec la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
européenne le 1er janvier prochain
donc il ya plus de raisons d'accorder
une réduction à ces quatre états que
sont les pays bas le danemark
la suède et l'autriche mais ils veulent
conserver cette réduction
cet avantage est évidemment ils
l'utilisent comme un moyen de
négociation pour bouger sur la
proposition de la commission
par ailleurs je pense qu'ils sont assez
hostile à ce qu' il y ait autant de
subventions budgétaires 500 milliards
alors paraît beaucoup la partie pré pose
moins de problème mais pour la partie
dont la partie subventions ils veulent
qu'il y ait des contreparties c'est à
dire des engagements d'utilisation très
très très stricte par les états qui en
bénéficieront il va donc falloir trouver
un équilibre parce que l'italie est déjà
dit qu'elle ne voulait pas être soumises
à une tutelle de bruxelles pour
l'utilisation de ces fonds voilà pour la
négociation la plus immédiate mais hier
en effet beaucoup d'autres sujets qui
ont été évoqués par la chancelière et
par le président et y compris des sujets
de politique internationale
vous avez évoqué en ces réticences des
pays dits frugaux est-ce que avec
justement cette résistance cette
initiative franco allemande at elle des
chances de voir le jour
écoutez oui parce que les pays frugaux
ont une grande déception c'est que leur
chef de file était jusqu'à il ya deux
mois
madame merkel l'allemagne or il se
trouve que après mûre réflexion
l'allemagne a vu que son intérêt bien
compris et est de sauver le marché
unique et par conséquent d'aider les
pays qui étaient les plus affectées par
la crise est là elle essaie depuis d'en
convaincre les quatre autres pays avec
lesquels elle était de cette opinion en
est en effet de ne pas engager les
dépenses supplémentaires à ce titre
alors ça c'est un événement important
parce qu'ils ont perdu leur leader et
l'économie la plus puissante de l'union
européenne et ça les expose beaucoup par
ailleurs les pays bas pays fondateurs
aussi de l'union européenne ont une
tradition européenne à l'origine
d'ailleurs il était beaucoup plus
intégrationniste que la france
il voulait tout intégré dans l'union
européenne est aujourd'hui se retrouve
un petit peu
un petit peu a compris à contre-pied il
est possible d'ailleurs qu' on est plus
de fil à retordre avec des pays comme
l'autriche ou comme des pays comme la
suède ou le danemark qui ont adhéré plus
récemment à l'union européenne et pour
des raisons qui tiennent surtout aux
avantages commerciaux qu'ils en retirent
alors un gala merkel justement dans ces
conditions à ce qu'elle a selon vous au
claude manche maison une occasion de
marquer l'histoire high kick it on le
rappelle le pouvoir à la fin de son
mandat en 2021
oui d'ailleurs vous pouvez vous voyez
vous pouvez vérifier que angela merkel a
actuellement des sondages qui ce qui lui
sont très favorables en allemagne où la
population considère en général qu'elle
a bien géré la crise et puis son image
de mutti merkel comme ont lieu en
allemagne maman merkel protectrice qui
en est fait plett aux allemands elle a
par ailleurs une voix très importante au
sein des instances européennes
parce qu'elle a beaucoup d'expérience
elle a déjà géré une présidence
allemande et on attend beaucoup de ce
semestre en effet le président
je pense aussi qu'elle veut laisser son
nom dans l'histoire dans l'histoire de
l'allemagne mais aussi dans l'histoire
de l'europe avant de quitter la
chancellerie dans un an et demi alors au
menu également des discussions les
négociations post break site la chine
les etats unis mais aussi la russie que
peut-on en attendre
or je pense que tout le monde souhaite
que la négociation du break 6 2 se passe
bien c'est il ya un accord sur le régime
des échanges entre la grande bretagne
ont leur wyoming grande bretagne et le
continent
mais ça n'est pas sûr qu'on y arrive et
monsieur boris johnson ne fait rien pour
qu'on y arrive et il
donnent l'impression qu'ils se
contenteraient d'un break site sans
accord il faut donc s'y préparer et il
est probable que le chancelier le
président la chancelière et le président
ont parlé de cette hypothèse s'agissant
de la russie j'imagine que le président
macron a parlé à la chancelière de son
projet de voyage à moscou pour
rencontrer le président poutine pour
parler très généralement des problèmes
de sécurité en europe mais aussi pour
évoquer la question ukrainienne bien sûr
et puis pour parler de la syrie et de la
lubie libye où il a estimé que certains
progrès étaient possibles dans une
discussion avec la russie
et puis d'autres sujets bien sûr la
turquie puisque la turquie a une
attitude très offensive en libye
offensive est offensante aussi pour la
france puisqu'elle elle s'en est pris à
un navire de la marine française il ya
peu de temps en le menaçant parce que ça
c'est tout simplement parce que ce
navire voulait contrôler que le navire
turc ne transportait pas des arbres vous
savez qu'il ya un embargo sur les armes
qui a été décidé par les par l'onu par
ailleurs la turquie a transporté en
libye des milices pro turc qui se
battaient auparavant en syrie donc ça
fait quand même beaucoup pour la turquie
merci beaucoup aux claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales